we're going to begin at the southern
border where the end of a pandemic era
policy is causing fear that there will
be a new humanitarian crisis along that
border that policy title 42 had allowed
authorities to swiftly expel migrants on
the grounds of Public Health due to the
coronavirus that measure expired however
overnight raising concerns that there
will be a new wave of border crossings
and in fact it's estimated there are
tens of thousands of potential Asylum
seekers in Mexico right now waiting to
enter the U.S Manuel bojorquez is along
the border for us he's in El Paso Texas
that's where we find them where it is
still dark Manny good morning
good morning the city of El Paso is
beefing up its police presence and
asking residents to remain Vigilant on
some days border patrol has apprehended
up to ten thousand migrants and the
chief says that number could go up
at points all across the southern U.S
border migrant men women and children
can be seen arriving as title 42 expires
bring it this way about 400 have camped
near the border in El Paso Texas where
National Guard members erected barbed
wire migrants there were given a choice
returned to Mexico or board buses to
processing centers but we're going to
prevent any further migrants from
joining the group that's already here in
San Ysidro California the busiest port
of entry in the U.S hundreds of people
including toddlers braved rain and heat
using blankets
says she fled Peru with her two sons to
escape domestic abuse and government
instability
border patrol estimates about 60
thousand migrants are waiting in
northern Mexico while some 25 000 sit in
holding facilities where resources are
severely limited there's a host of tools
at our disposal border patrol Chief Raul
Ortiz says authorities will now lean on
protocols outlined by the decades-old
title eight under which migrants can be
deported from the United States back to
their home countries and given a
five-year ban on re-entry unless they
express fear of returning and pass an
interview what's your biggest concern
going forward making sure that our
agents are safe out there making sure
those communities are safe and making
sure that you know we respond to those
migrants that are in distress this is an
invasion and they want the numbers to go
up in Washington Republicans are
efforting last-minute legislation with a
house passing a border security Bill
yesterday but the Democratic Senate
majority calls it Dead on Arrival the
White House produced no plan missed the
deadline
and bumbled into another crisis
adding to the overcrowding concerns a
federal judge in Florida dealt the Biden
Administration a blow just as title 42
was expiring ruling against something
called expedited release from holding
facilities for migrants who are dealt or
who are deemed not to be a public risk
the Biden Administration is expected to
seek an emergency stay of that ruling